agnès on est allé sur vos pas l'i p e
pers et blaise grenier oui ce discret je
trouve ont rencontré deux interlocuteurs
privilégiés
didier douce à la wii photographe et un
de vos au cadreur et aurélie train et
rosalie votre fille oui si juste en
costume ou les a suivis tous les deux
ans commençant par le fameux passage du
gois d'accès de l'île de noirmoutier
bien sûr c'est ce fameux passage du gois
son qu'elle nous sommes en ce moment la
mer sont retirés s'ils deux fois par
jour chaque marée basse
quelques minutes avait traversé la route
et après il faudra attendre 12 heures
pour pouvoir traverser
passé le gua ça reste quelque chose de
magique et on passe toujours par le
boîte dès qu'on peut une route qui fait
que tu as mètres de long un peu plus de
quatre kilomètres
on est en train de traverser la mer
peut-être que meneuse est passée par là
d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui connaissent la camargue ça
ressemble assez à la camargue serre
c'est très plat sont des paysages des
marais il ya des champs de patates mais
c'est quand même essentiellement du
marais je photographie noirmoutier
depuis 1976 à savoir l'année où j'ai
commencé la photo cette première était
où j'étais ici là on arrive dans un
arrêt que j'affectionne particulièrement
été remis en état il ya quatre ans il
est abandonné depuis une vingtaine
d'années et là ça y est ce loup en
activité la 40 e lle en service les ayez
ce sont les partis qu'on voit là chaque
oeil et est un en gros on récupère le
sel fait tout petit peu froid car la
particularité d'un routier si ces deux
silhouettes le château et l'église de
noirmoutier convoi d' absolument partout
et quand on est en mer c'est aussi des
repères
l'outil c'est un port et des ruelles du
vieux de vieux noirmoutier quartier de
bang est actuellement magnifique avec
ses volets bleus ses petites ruelles
c'est pas beau toutes ses couleurs de
paniers la voulait faire même le fait
qu'ils sont
autant photographier les gens partent
parce que géniale ici c'est que je suis
complètement transparent les gens ont
tellement l'habitude de voir tu peux
faire des portraits 200 qui sans qu'ils
soient impressionnés par l'appareil
une passion commune que j'ai avec agnès
le portrait des gens plus grandes
photographes inez garde
on a tourné ici avec elle
viens régulièrement aussi d'ailleurs sa
fille est ici en ce moment
tous
[Musique]
alors là on est aux portes du bonhomme
et depuis mon arrivée sur cette île avec
mes parents une assez jacques ce port du
bonhomme a toujours été l'endroit où on
veut ni voir les mains
c'est un endroit que agnès aime parce
que elle se sent aussi comme moi très
proche de tout ce qu'on a ici et je
crois que ce port du bonhomme lui
rappelle la pointe-courte à 7 ce côté
cabanon pêcheurs petit les choses un peu
abîmée je crois qu'elle est aussi
énormément la plage devant devant le
moulin on habite mes parents l'ont
acheté au début des années 60
ayant entièrement restaurée alors là on
arrive sur la plage la plage de la
guérinière et la plage devant notre
maison
sa plage de mon enfance et mes racines
ici c'est une île je trouve qu'ils
aiment qui est inspirante s'est jamais
la même chose est toujours un peu pareil
[Applaudissements]
voilà un philippe jour présente philippe
et de personnes choisi selon philippe
elle était il ya quelques jours un grand
goûter vous ne cédez pas non je ne
savais pas c'est une bonne surprise
parce que effectivement c'est un paysage
que j'aime voir c'est cette une île qui
est très belle
j'ai été très bons souvenirs comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est jacky
me a amené et qui m'a jamais presque
dire fait connaître les marais je
connaissais que l'ami la méditerranée et
il m'a fait connaître cette sauvagerie
et cette beauté de la mer qui part et
qui revient et particulièrement sur la
route
nous on adorait avant le pont quand
valait il vraiment il fallait attendre
que la route soit dégagée si on se
trompait en attendait le bois le bois
souvent passer les vous dans l'eau en
ayant un petit peu de bon je suis
contente qu'on ait vu rosalie je fais en
bêta boulet n'est pas du tout facile et
tellement mignon nouvelle montée que de
dos avec ses cheveux en la fois la fin
on la voit pas du tout
comme tout on la voit pas par contre
j'ai aperçu la silhouette de m&i fils
adorent abba et 3
[Musique]